ha you know I this Kardashian Christmas  card I I really feel like last year  really just over I'm not gonna lie it  really did us in so we got to get it  together we got a plan ahead I think we  just time honestly flew by so fast I  think I'm gonna ask everyone if they'll  get there so this year is the first year  that Kanye and I are taking over the  Christmas Eve party we've done it at my  mom's house for the last like 20 years  so this year it's gonna be a mine and  Kanye's house still thrown by my mom and  all of us but I think if I tell everyone  that it's 30 minutes before the party  actually starts and they have to be on  time and have a photographer waiting and  have all of our outfits somewhat  cohesive we might be able to pull off a  really late Christmas card maybe a New  Year's card you're gonna bombard them  good I think so I'm gonna try to do that  that's my goal  [Music]